nothing in there about my trunk and your
lovely little portmanteau you're holding
a 62 edition of the SCCA you can stick
this bloody sticker hey Jim what seems
to be the problem is that Billy he
doesn't know the bill isn't silly I'm
just doing my job
Phil Billy in my experience there is
listen to me something like this there's
always a middle ground all right now
Ken's outta line I understand you are
you know how he gets on a race day you
know that all right but you're not gonna
dink he was over at Ron Harvey bill yeah
I am
why so happy things are changing the
Allies have taken Italy France will be
next and soon the war will be over
why does that make you Apple you hate
your countries as much I love my country
it's the war I hate it's pointless and
stupid and the sooner we have peace the
better oh the war will end we will crush
your enemies into dust and when they are
destroyed we shall use the greatest war
okay no more politics dinner is neutral
ground stable Switzerland let's eat
you aren't eating no I am not that
hungry
I might eat later for now I'm just going
to chew on these grapes well I'm
especially hungry tonight so maybe I'll
just finish yours don't want it to go to
waste
[Music]
Arthur does it help you have someone to
talk to
[Music]
my mother always tells me to smile and
put on a happy face
she told me I had a purpose to bring
laughter and joy to the world
is it just me or is it getting crazier
out there
though your harvies Aiken smile even
though it's breaking when there are
cloud in the sky
you'll get by but if you see sorrows
maybe tomorrow
[Music]
what's so funny
just freak
[Music]
Gotham's lost its way
[Music]
what kind of coward would do something
that cold-blooded someone who hides
behind a mask
[Music]
I used to think that my life was a
tragedy
[Music]
it's a comedy
[Music]
[Music]
you just
I've always known I would marry rich why
should I be ashamed of that it's nothing
to be ashamed of as long as you love him
well I believe we have some power over
who we love it isn't something that just
happens to a person I think the poet's
night disagree well I'm not a poet I'm
just a woman and as a woman there's no
way for me to make my own money not
enough to earn a living or to support my
family and if I had my own money which I
don't that money would belong to my
husband the moment we got married and if
we had children they would be his not
mine
they would be his property so don't sit
there and tell me that marriage isn't an
economic proposition because it is may
not be for you but it most certainly is
for me
what I love about Nicole
she's a great dancer infectious she's a
mother who plays really plays she gives
great presence
[Music]
she's imperative she knows when to push
me
and when to leave me long
[Music]
as always should talk okay I don't know
how to start hey Randy what so you still
with Rekha still here in there yeah just
not does it look just just did just put
him in the wardrobe all right
and what's it gonna hurt then if you
need them you got them all right I have
a conversation with that wardrobe
assistant and man she's a [ __ ] I just
don't please I'm asking you to help me
out man yeah if the answer's no the
answer's no not not no with excuses hey
man this ain't a Andy McLaughlin fixture
and I can't afford to hire a bunch of
guys that smoke cigarettes and sit
around talking to each other all day on
the chance that I might use them I got a
four man team here Rick I need more than
that I got to get it approved and you
know I got a look after my juice hey and
if your dudes were a better match for me
I'd say oh okay you got me but that's
not the case and you know it he's a
great match yeah yeah hey you could do
anything you want to him don't throw him
off a building right light him on fire
hit with a blanket right get creative do
whatever you want he's happy for the
opportunity yeah yeah I don't dig him
and I don't think the vibe he brings on
a set the coochie
that's her aren't you welcome suitable
who touch acquire in the money over g20
huge on upon Jedi was haircut I'll never
know get her husband onto the predict
boxing cocoons I'm sorry
so I'm gonna push yourself
[Music]
from the parched
and I'm only tunnel
take care of the Monday
- a mighty reimagining whoa
can you believe this weather Frank huh
it's 85 degrees outside perfect hey
Vijay people freezing to death in New
York and look at us John pagan why we
don't live here all year round what I
want to know
beautiful it's summer what it's summer
people are freezing to death in New York
it's summer my mind it's always eight
degrees in New York I'm making a point
I'm making a point making a point just
like that
I saw your dress form even done this is
how you dress in Florida and a soup for
meeting anywhere Florida Timbuktu HS in
a suit for a meeting and you're late
what you leave then it was traffic yeah
it's traffic
I wasn't a traffic you give me the next
traffic what do you what do you want for
us it was bumper to buy another it's bad
you know
traffic I never waited for anyone who
was late more than 10 minutes in my life
let's say 15 15 right no Tim I don't
think so
that's not enough you have to take
traffic into account if that's that's
what I'm doing
I'm taking traffic into account that's
why it's 10:00 I still say 15 no 10 fine
we disagree on that how about 12 and a
half minute middle right no no beautiful
beautiful more than 10 is Saints him you
say something to me come here hmm
it says what it says
you
[Music]